first i want to say congratulations on
both black widow and
no sudden move um because i've seen both
and you're great in
both films when did you decide you
wanted to own
july at the at the box office
it was uh sometime last year i was
thinking
what's the month for me and i came up
with july i mean it is independence day
after all july 4th and i was like
let's let's do it then and i called all
the studios and i was like let's make it
happen no steve i had
come on i had no say in this
well it's going to be a good good two
weeks for you um yeah
when you first uh got approached for red
guardian
i'm curious did feige or anyone at
marvel tell you
like we this is our plan for multiple
films or
was it sort of like because i think they
make everyone sign these multi-picture
deals
so did you sort of have any any inkling
of like where it's all gonna go
or is it like one at a time um
there is some chatter around certain
things
but uh they
they we were pretty focused on just this
and uh you know they also have like a
lot of stuff
in the pipe that is you know it seems
like in this particular phase
that there's a lot of different you know
there's like eternals
and there's like different there's
different elements to this universe that
i think they're branching out
at this point until they start to do
this
and so i don't i i knew i wasn't
involved in the
that bran that my branch has a certain
branch and so
the discussions were um you know they
didn't really give
a sense of what was up next it was more
just really focused on this movie and
you know some speculation of
possibilities but
no i think after people see this movie
they're going to want a lot more of you
in florence
oh thanks ah that's very sweet of you i
appreciate that
very confident um so i spoke to joe
russo a while back and he said that the
extraction sequel
could be a prequel so i'm just curious
if you have any plans to be working with
chris hemsworth later this year
uh that's a good question um
i think it was announced
i think it was announced that it it will
be a sequel but i will say that um
[Music]
you know i do know that there there
there has been talk and apparently there
is some work
starting on what possibly could be
something else
i know joe was very excited about my
character and the dynamic that chris and
i had
chris and i really like that so and i
like that whole world of extraction and
i think joe's really good at world
building so
there has been some talk at netflix uh
that's all i can really say
but um it won't i think chris
is moving on in the sequel area but
there is there is talk about doing other
things with
yeah i want that movie to happen
obviously you are currently filming
stranger things four
and i'm just curious obviously he's a
huge fan of the series
and i know you can't say much but can
you sort of talk about
whatever the hell you can say and maybe
how this season compares to the previous
ones
i mean it's bigger that's uh the first
thing in scope
in scale even in the idea that we're not
in hawkins anymore
uh we locale wise are
we're bigger um and then in terms of
you know we're introducing new stuff
but we're also tightening and wrapping
up
in a certain direction to make it have
a clear clean specific and definite
ending at some
point which i can't really talk about
but um
i and i i mean i can really only talk i
can talk about hopper
er so far
it's i guess i say this about a lot of
seasons but it's
it's my favorite season in the sense
that he's at his
purest he's that is most vulnerable in a
sense i mean he's been
as we've seen he's in this russian
prison so we get to reinvent him in a
sense i mean he gets to have a rebirth
from what he had become and i've always
always sort of planned
this um this almost
resurrection of like you have uh
you have gandalf dyes getting off the
gray and sort of re-emerge and i
i'm really interested in this resurgence
of him we get to explore a lot of
threads in his life that have been
merely hinted at that will um
that we get to see a lot more of and
there's some real surprises that you
know nothing about
that will start to come out in this and
play big as the series goes on um
but it's really my favorite season i
just love it all the scripts always get
better and these guys they started out
the thing season one is so tight and
good and intimate in a certain way
it's so good and these guys go in
different directions of which the fans
have multiple takes on but i will say
the writing continues to be of its
particular
specific genre whatever they're doing
each season
is just extraordinary and this again we
top it like i feel like it's a big
beautiful season
i can't wait for people to see it can't
wait thank you so much for your time
good luck with the rest of the speed
dating
thanks